allez on reste au restaurant avec le
guide michelin le fameux guide rouge qui
se lance à la conquête de l'amérique une
première édition consacrée à new york
sort cette semaine quatre restaurants
obtiennent à les trois étoiles parmi eux
quelle surprise trois sont français sur
place à new york pascal golomer frissant
lebrun après trente ans de métier
alain ducasse peut se permettre de ne
plus être derrière les fourneaux c'est
le chef de sa cuisine new yorkaise tony
est nous qui lui fait goûter
l'un de ses plats préférés la cocotte de
fruits et de légumes d'automne cela
paraît si star pour michelin cela vaut
par sa perfection les trois étoiles les
étoiles qui viennent s'ajouter à celles
obtenues dans ses autres restaurants
français à monaco douze au total pour le
même homme
un record et pour alain ducasse se font
au nord aujourd'hui ce sont une cuisine
et des produits américains
derrière un produit nommé une femme et
c'est partout pareil
après nous français on va y apporter
notre expertise et notre savoir faire
mais en réalité la cuisine aujourd'hui
ici et autant américaines que françaises
c'est le savoir faire qui est français
mais la proposition elle est adaptée au
marché américain
pour cette première édition new yorkaise
le guide n'a retenu que 500 restaurants
sur les vingt mille que compte la ville
des restaurants testés par une équipe
d'inspecteurs chevronnés venus d'europe
et la sélection elle se veut à l'image
de la ville ouverte sur le monde sur les
propres et fais-toi nous avons 14
différents types de cuisine aujourd'hui
ceux qui sont les plus grands pour que
les caps trois étoiles pour
effectivement des noms de chaque
français ont été des chefs ont fait
pendant très très longtemps mais sont à
new york depuis plus de 20 ans l'islam
aura aussi distinguer les aventuriers
comme wylie dufresne et sa cuisine
d'avant garde parfois déroutant
heureuse et surpris de son étoile il ne
peut maintenant souhaitait qu'une chose
que les gourmets new yorkais adopte le
guide pour faire leur choix